faire de la bande annonce un art à part
entière
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé la ville
de bois d'arcy il y a trois ans avec le
festival béaba la ville compte bien
montrer que ce petit film résumant leurs
grands frères sont un vrai travail
il ya des bandes-annonces magnifique des
bandes annonces qui vous donne envie
d'aller voir un film
des bandes annonces qui sont des films
en tant que tel et il fallait rendre
hommage à cette a7 à cet art qui a été
oubliée jusqu'à maintenant le festival
est désormais bien installé aucun
fauteuil vide dans la salle qui a même
dû refuser une centaine de paires qu'est
ce que vous voulez lever le doigt ceux
qui étaient là au moins une fois déjà
venu aux oreilles
la soirée était rythmée par des
thématiques avec un hommage à bourvil
les grands classiques ou encore les
couples à la scène comme à la ville
nous allons ce soir nous promener
pendant deux heures dans toute
l'histoire du cinéma et on va avoir 34
films mais oui parce que d'une certaine
façon c'est vrai c'est dans une version
résumée
mais on voit 34 films etc ce qui
logiquement doit donner aussi envie d'en
voir d'autres et de revoir ce dont on a
assisté à la projection de la bande
annonce
nouveauté cette année on passe de
l'autre côté de l'écran avec
l'intervention de l'uqam à son un jeune
réalisateur français de bande annonce
venu présenter son métier
la clé c'est de donner envie aux
spectateurs et c'est de se donner envie
à soi même aussi c'est pour moi c'est
une passion et c'est que c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment stimulant et il
faut que ce soit donc que ce finalement
c'est cette envie et que ce côté
stimulant se traversent l'écran et
arrivent jusqu au public pour qu'il
vienne en salle le festival s'est
poursuivi le lendemain avec son édition
junior au vu du succès de cette
troisième édition les organisateurs
réfléchissent déjà aux thèmes de l'année
prochaine
[Musique]